สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูกุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
คอมพ H ไยห้องเรียนภาษาไทยค่ะแล้วก็ในวัน
นี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบกับทุกๆคน
นะคะในวันนี้ค่ะวันอะไรคะครูชิวันศุกร์มี
ความสุขอืมอืนะวันนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 15 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะธันวาคม
ค่ะอ่าธันวาคมเนี่ยเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่
คะ 12 ค่ะอแล้วก็ปีพุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่
คะ
2566 ค่ะปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2023 ค่ะค่ะครุูปุครููชิก็มาพบกับทุกคน
ในวันศุกร์นะคะวันที่ 15 เดือนธันวาคม
เป็นเดือนที่ 12 นะคะแล้วก็ปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะว้าวกูชิเดือน 12
แล้ว
โอ้โห 2  5  6  6 หรือ 2  0  2  3 เนี่ย
กำลังจะบ๊ายบายแล้วค่ะกำลังจะไปแล้ว
อืกำลังจะเปลี่ยนใหม่แล้วนะคะโไหนๆวันนี้
เดือน
ธันวาคมค่ะแล้วยังไงคะเดือน
ธันวาคมก็มีทุกปีค่ะครูชิก็เลยอยากจะมา
ชวนครูปุ๊กมาย้อนหลังย้อนไปอดีตค่ะตอนที่
เราเด็กเด็กเราก็มีนิทานเนาะนิทานที่มี
เจ้าหญิงเจ้าชายนะคะเจ้าหญิงก็มีผู้หญิง
ใส่มงกุฎใช่มั้ยอ่าเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเจ้า
หญิงเนี่ยก็ต้องเป็นลูกของพระราชาค่ะนี่
พระราชาพระราชาก็ต้องแต่งงานค่ะกับพระ
ราชินี
อ่านะถ้ามีลูกออกมาเป็นผู้ชายก็เป็นเจ้า
ชายอื้อหือถ้ามีลูกออกมาเป็นผู้หหญิงก็จะ
เป็นเจ้าหญิงค่ะนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยพระ
ราชาหรือว่าในหลวงเนาะนะพระราชินีอือเจ้า
ชายเจ้าหญิงโอ้โหชอบ
ค่ะใช่มยตอนเด็กๆเนี่ยเราก็จะชอบฟัง
เรื่องที่เป็นแบบเจ้าหญิงเจ้าชายนะคะแล้ว
ก็ก็มีเรื่องเจ้าหญิงเจ้าชายเยอะนะครู
ปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบนิทานานที่เป็นเจ้าหญิงเจ้า
ชายเรื่องอะไรอ่ะ
อ๋อเจ้าหญิงเจ้าชายเหรอคะโอ้โหจริงๆชอบ
ทุกทุกคนเลยค่ะไม่ว่าจะเป็นสโนวไวท์
ซินเดอเรลล่า
โอหอื้อหืออืออะไรอีกอ่ะูชิ be  and  the
brid ไม่ใช่อ้าวไม่ใช่เจ้าหญิงเหรอคะไม่
ใช่ค่ะไม่เจ้าชายไงเพราะว่าเบลเนี่ยเบล
เนี่ยเป็นเป็นลูกของคนธรรมดาไม่ได้คุณพ่อ
ไม่ได้เป็นในหลวงไม่ได้เป็นราชินีค่ะคุณ
แม่ไม่ได้เป็นราชินีแต่ได้แต่งงานกับเจ้า
ชายไง
โอ้โหแต่เขาเอ้าก็นี่ไงก็บอกว่าเ้าเป็น
ลูกของในหลวงไงเอ้าแล้วสโนว์ไวท์เอ้ไม่
ใช่แล้วซินเดอเรลล่าล่ะซินเดอเรลล่าก็ไม่
ใช่เจ้าหญิงไงแต่แต่งงานกับเจ้าชายไงเออ
เออเนาะเออใช่เนาะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเจ้า
หญิงเนี่ยอ๋อเป็นผู้หญิงธรรมดาไปแต่งงาน
กับเจ้าชายก็ได้ใช่มยใช่แต่ต้องเรื่องนี้
ค่ะเวลาเราฟังแล้วเรารู้สึกว่าโอ้โหมัน
เป็นเรื่องที่แปลกมากเพราะว่าคนเนี่ย
ครึ่งนึงเป็นคนครึ่งนึงเป็นปลาค่ะอ่ะครู
ชิครึ่งผิดแล้วค่ะอะไรคอันนี้ไม่ใช่ครึ่ง
ซ้ายครึ่งขวาค่ะครึ่ง
บนข้างบนข้างล่างค่ะข้างบนเนี่ยเป็นคน
ข้างล่างเป็นปลาเรืื่องนี้คือชิชอบมากนะ
อะไรอ่ะครูชิเจ้าหญิงเลือกน้อย
อ๋อเพราะว่าชื่อภาษาอังกฤษมันเป็น Little
ใช่มั้ยอืมอืมนะเงือกตัวเล็กๆโอ้เจ้าหญิง
เงือกน้อยใช่มั้ยคะตัวเล็กใช่มั้ยใช่
ค่ะก็เลยแบบอยากจะให้ครูกุ๊กเล่าเรื่อง
นี้ให้ฟังไงเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยอ่ะนี่ไงคะ
ครูชิใช่ๆครูชิชอบมากนะคะเอาเรื่องนี้ค่ะ
ครูปุ๊กอ๋ออยากเล่าเรื่องนี้ให้นักเรียน
ฟังหรอคะนะใช่ๆเพราะว่ามีเจ้าหญิงคือจริง
ๆแล้วเนี่ยที่ครูชิชอบเนี่ยเพราะว่าครู
ชิเเนี่ยเป็นคนชอบทะเลใช่ๆๆชอบว่ายน้ำใช่
คูชิเนี่ยคิดตัวเองเนี่ยเป็นแอเรียล
ค่ะคิดตัวเองเป็นเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยใช่
มั้ยใช่ๆอืแล้วครูชิคิดนะถ้าเกิดครูชิ
เป็นเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยครูชิจะว่ายน้ำดู
ประการังค่ะโอ้โหครูชิได้ว่ายน้ำทั้งวัน
ทั้งคืนค่ะใช่แล้วครูชิจะลงไปใต้ทะเลใต้
มหาสมุทรลงไปลึกๆแล้วก็ใชมหาสมุทรเนี่ย
มันก็ลึกๆๆมากเลยนะครูชิเราก็จะมีใช่มั้ย
ทะเลทะเลเนี่ยก็เล็กๆถ้าเป็นมหาสมุทร
เนี่ยก็เป็นแบบใหญ่มากเช่นมหาสมุทรแ
มหาสมุทรแอตแลนติกมหาสมุทร
แอนตาร์กติกว้าวูชินี่เลยูปุ๊กเจอเพื่อน
กูชิเยอะแยะเลยค่ะนี่ไงใช่นะคะแล้วกูชิ
ว่าเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยเนี่ยก็มีพี่แล้วก็
มีน้องนะด้วยกันมีพี่น้องทั้งหมด 6 คนใช่
มั้ยอืแต่ตัวเองเป็นคนน้องสุดออเป็นน้อง
เล็กสุดเราเรียกว่าน้องสุดท้องอือหืออ่า
ใช่มยก็มีพี่ๆมีพี่กี่คนนะคะ
คุชิมีพี่ 6 คนใช่มั้ยเดี๋ยวนะ 1  2  3  4
5  6  6 คนค่ะ
เอ้ามีพี่ไม่จำ
ได้งั้นก็เจ้าหญิงเนี่ยก็เป็นลูกคนที่ 7
หรอคะใช่ค่ะเหมือนออสโนไวท์มีคนแคะนะ 7
คนแต่อันนี้เงือก 7 คนใช่มั้ยเป็นคนมั้ย
เอก็พอเราบอกว่าเจ้าหญิงเราก็เรียกเป็น
องค์ค่ะ 1 องค์ 2 องค์ 3 องค์ 4 องค์เจ้า
หญิงเนี่ยมีทั้งหมด 7 องค์เพราะว่าเป็น
ลูกของเจ้าสมุท
อ๋อราชาไตรตันเนี่ยนะเป็นเจ้าสมุ
ใช่ค่ะ
ออดูแลมหาสมุทร
แอตแลนติก้าไม่ใช่แปซิฟิกแอตแลนติไม่ใช่
หรอคะไม่ใช่อมหาสมุทรแอตแลนติก้าไม่รู้
อยู่ไหนนะอือยู่ในดิสนีย์
ค่ะก็เป็นมหาสมุทรใหญ่ก็มีพระราชาที่เรา
เรียกว่าเจ้าสมุทรใช่มั้ยใช่เพราะว่าดูแล
มหาสมุด
นะแล้วก็ดูหน้าตาเนี่ยโอ้โหก็น่ากลัว
เหมือนกันนะูชิแล้วก็มีอาวุธค่ะไม่ใช่ปืน
ไม่ใช่ระเบิด
บุ้มแล้วเป็นอะไรคะเออนะเป็นอันนี้มันมี 3
ง่ามเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าตีนะเอโทตีเออ๋อไม่
ใช่ัน
ไม่ใช่1ททค่ะภาษาเก่าเราเรียกเอกโทตรีตรี
สูอืมก็เป็นสง่ามเนาะอ
นะเป็นอาวุธของเจ้าสมุทรหรือราชาไตตันใน
เรื่องเนาะนะแล้วก็พี่น้องพี่ๆเนี่ยก็
อยู่ไม่ไปไหนเนาะชอบอยู่บ้านแต่ทำไมครู
ชิเเนี่ยแอเรียลเนี่ยชอบไปเที่ยวคะหูก็
ชอบไงเวลาเห็นเรือใช่มั้ยเจอพายุมีพายุมา
แล้วก็เรือเนี่ยจมค่ะปกติเรือเนี่ยลอยอ่า
เวลาเจอพายุมาน้ำเข้าไปน้ำเข้าไปเรือก็จม
บุมๆๆๆๆๆมๆๆอ๋อเรือร่มนะพอเรือร่มเนี่ย
เรือเนี่ยเหมือนไททานิคเนาะก็จมลงใน
มหาสมุทรนะแล้วนะเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยเนี่ย
ก็จะชอบไปหาของที่เป็นของเกี่ยวกับที่คน
เนี่ยคนเนี่ยเอาไปใช่มยเพราะว่ามีของสวยๆ
เยอะอุ๊ยแต่น่ากลัวนะูชิกลัวฉลามมยคะไม่
กลัวเ้าเพราะว่าเป็นเป็นเจ้าหญิงเ้าว่าย
น้ำเก่ง
ออว่ายน้ำเร็วกว่าฉลามเหรอคะก็ซิกแซกได้
นะคะเพราะว่าฉลาดมากกว่าฉลามไงอ๋อไอคิดี
ใช่ค่ะ
นะทีนี้แน่นอนทุกวันเนี่ยเอ่อนางเงือกใช่
มยเงือกน้อยของเราเนี่ยก็จะไห้ไปเก็บของ
เป็นของใช้ของมนุษย์นะมนุษย์ก็คือคนเนี่ย
แบบครูปุ๊กก็เป็นมนุษย์ครูชิก็เป็นมนุษย์
หรือคนอื
นะแล้วไม่ไม่ชอบอะไรของเงือกหรอคะไม่ชอบ
บางทีมีตลับแป้งโอ้โหมีกระจกใช่มั้ยมี
หวีมันไม่ใช่หวีแบบนี้ค่ะกูชิอันนี้หวี
แต่นี่ค่ะอะไรคะ
หวีหวีมี 3 อัน 4 หรอเออ 4 อันมี 4  1  2
3  4
ถ้าอยู่ข้างบนเนี่ยเอาไว้จิ้ม
สเต็กไม่ใช่แต่ว่าเค้าไม่รู้ไงว่าซ่อม
เนี่ยมีไว้สำหรับกินอาหารเนาะอื้อหือนะก็
คิดว่าโอ๊เอามาหวีผมโอ๊ดีมากเลยนะแล้วก็
เลยไปชอบไปหาตามที่มีเรือใช่มยเรือเนี่ย
ใช่ร่มหรือนะอยู่ใต้ทะเลนะแล้วก็อูยูชิคะ
น่ากลัวชอ
โหก็มีอยู่ครั้งนึงค่ะครูปุ๊กได้ยินว่ามี
เรือของเจ้าชายค่ะเรือของเจ้าชายเนี่ยมา
แล้วบนเรือนะก็จัดงานเหมือนกับเอ่อจัดงาน
สังสรมีปาร์ตี้เนาะปารตี้
ออน่าจะฉลองอะไรให้เจ้าชายก็มีเสียงดัง
Happy  Birthday เจ้าชายแฮปป Birthday
เจ้าชายใช่มั้ยน่าจะใช่นางเงือกน้อยก็
ไหว้ไปแล้วก็เห็นเจ้าชายครั้งแรกก็ปิ๊ง
[เพลง]
ๆรักแรกพบเหรอคะใช่ค่ะเห็นครั้งแรกก็รู้
สึกโอ๊ยหล่อจังรักเลยเห็นมยดูตาโอโหแสดง
ว่าไม่ค่อยเห็นผู้ชาย
เนาะก็เจ้าชายหล่อไงหล่ออออ่าเส็จแล้ว
เกิดอะไรขึ้นคะูชิเกิดพายุค่ะไม่รู้
ทอร์นาโดหรือเอ่อไต้ฝุ่นเฮอร์ริเคน
เฮอร์ริเคนมาเลยเรือก็แบบเรือเจ้าชายก็
ล่มเจ้าชายก็จมค่ะ
อืมจมลงไปในน้ำำนางเงือกน้อยก็ไหว้ไปแล้ว
ก็ช่วยเจ้าชายค่ะนี่ช่วยไปที่หาด
อ้า
อืแล้วก็เอาเจ้าชายไปที่ชายหาดนะแล้วก็
ร้องเพลงนะ
อ่าคือจริงๆถ้าเกิดแบบคนเราเนี่ยจมน้ำ
แล้วเราจะช่วยเนี่ยเราก็จะต้องแบบายปอด
ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็
อ่าช่วยแต่นางเงือกเนี่ยใช้วิธีการร้อง
เพลงเพราะว่านางเงือกมีเสียงเพลงเหมือนๆ
เป็นปุกตืนนะออเสียงเพราะมากต้องเสียงแบบ
อะไรอ่ะเหมือนวินนี่ฮูสตันเหรอ
คะตื่นแน่นอนค่ะถ้าเสียงกู
ปุ๊กอันเนี้ยตื่นเพราะอยากจะเอาอะไรแบบ
ร้อง
หยุด
แต่อันเนี้ยไม่เพราะเพราะว่าครูชิไม่
เพราะเหรอคะครูปุ๊กร้องไม่เพราะเหรอคะ
เพราะค่ะเพราะนิดหน่อยนะฮะครูปุ๊กต้องไป
ฝึกอีกหน่อยจะได้เพราะมากๆนะคะทีเนี้ย
เอ่อเงือกน้อยก็เลยเอ่อได้ยินใช่มั้ยมีคน
มาก็เลยรีบไปแต่เจ้าชายเนี่ยได้ยินเสียง
อ่ะได้ยินเสียงไพเราะเนี่ยออจำได้ก็ก็
เหมือนกับเค้าเรียกอะไรงัวเงียก็คือ
เหมือนกับกำลังจะตื่นสลึมสะลืออ่าสลึม
สะลือก็คือกำลังแบบเหมือนเรากำลังจะลุกจะ
ได้จะตื่นเนาะมันก็ยังแบบไม่อไม่ 100
เปอร์เซ
อืพอตื่นขึ้นมาก็อ้าไม่เห็นใครแล้วใช่มย
ก็เลยจำได้ว่ามันมีเสียงเพราะๆเนี่ยเป็น
คนที่ช่วยที่ช่วยเจ้าชายเจ้าชายก็จำไว้
แต่นางเงือกน้อยของเราเนี่ยพอกลับมาก็คิด
ถึงไงอ๋อ
คึงไม่อยู่รอเจ้าชายฟื้นไงูชิเอ้าก็เจ้า
ชายแล้วก็เป็นปลาไงมีครึ่งนึงเป็นคนครึ่ง
นึงเป็นปลาเป็นนางเงือกเนี่ยเดี๋ยวเจ้า
ชายก็ตกใจไงก็เลยคิดอยากจะเปลี่ยนตัวเอง
ให้เป็นคนก่อนแล้วค่อยไปหาเจ้าชายอืก็เลย
ไปหาู้ผู้หญิงน่ากลัวอย่างที่ครูปุ๊กบอก
ไง
อ๋อก็คือไปหาแม่มดแม่มดแห่งท้องทะเล
เอซาจริงๆเป็นเป็นเป็นอะไรนะใช่มั้ยปลา
หมึกยักษ์ปลาหมึกยักปลาหมึกยักษ์อือหือเอ
เป็นหมึกโอ้โหน่าจะเอามาบาร์บีคิว
ค่ะแม่มดแห่งท้องทะเลเอลซ่าก็บอก
ว่าเจ้าอยากจะเป็นมนุษย์เหรอเจ้าอยากจะ
เป็นคนเหรอเราให้เจ้าเป็นมนุษย์ได้ 3 วัน
แต่ต้องมีข้อแรกเปลี่ยนเอาเงินใช่มั้ยไม่
เจ้ามีเสียงที่ไพเราะอืมเอาเสียงไพเราะ
ของเจ้ามาแล้วเราจะให้ขาเจ้าเราให้เวลา
เจ้า 3 วันถ้าเมื่อไหร่เจ้าได้จุมพิษ
เออต้องปากกับปากเจ้า
ชาย
ว้าต้องจุมพิษด้วยความรักด้วยนะไม่ใช่
อยู่ๆจับเจ้าชายมาแล้วไม่ได้ผู้ชายต้อง
รักผู้หญิงต้องรักรักกันแล้วก็
จุมพิษจุ๊บกันอืขาก็จะเป็นของเธอแต่ถ้า 3
วันแล้วเจ้าชายยังไม่จุ๊บแล้วก็ไม่จุมพิษ
ล่ะก็ขาก็จะหายไปแล้วเสียงเธอก็จะเป็นของ
เรานะจุมพิษก็คือจูบใช่มยจูบภาษาธรรมดาก็
จูบนะเอาปากกับปากมาเจอกันจูบกันนะแล้วก็
ต้องจูบด้วยความรักด้วยต้องรักกันรักกัน
ภายใน 3 วันใช่ถ้า 3 วันแล้วยังนี่ทุก
อย่างจะเป็นของแม่หมดก็คือเาะใช่แล้วก็
เอ่อนางเงือกก็จะมีหางเหมือนเดิมไม่เป็น
ขาอย่างงี้ใช่มยใช่แม่มดก็เอาขวดมาค่ะ
แล้วก็ใส่เสียงแล้วก็ผูกเาห้อยเอาไว้อื
อ่านะนางเงือกตกลงทำสัญญากับก็เลยได้ขามา
ค่ะ
อืมพอได้ขามาแล้วเนี่ยแต่ตัวเอง
เอ้าไม่ไม่ไม่ใช่ว่าร้องเพลงไม่ได้เฉยๆ
ไม่มีเสียงเลยก็เอาเสียงไปแลกขามาแล้วไง
อ๋อก็เลยพูดไม่ได้อันนี้เป็นครูเอเอ่อสอน
ภาษาไทยไม่ได้ค่ะสอนสอนไม่ได้ค่ะนะ
คะพอตอนเช้าก็ไปพบเจ้าชายค่ะพอพบเจ้าชาย
แล้วตัวเองก็พูดไม่ได้ได้ร้องเพลงก็ไม่
ได้เจ้าชายรู้สึกสงสารก็เลยพาไปด้วยนะ
เพราะว่าเซ็กซี่ใช่มั้ยนะเพราว่าเห็นผู้
หญิงอยู่คนเดียวไงแล้วไม่มีบ้านนะก็เลย
เอามาอยู่ในวังค่ะอืแล้วก็เจอซ่อมเนอะก็
เอามาหวีผมเห็น
มั้ยตัวเองพูดไม่ได้เจ้าชายก็ไม่รู้นะว่า
เป็นคนที่ช่วยชีวิตตัวเอง
แต่คืออยู่ไปอยู่มาเนี่ย 2 คนเนี่ยนะวัน
ที่ 1 ก็ยังแบบพาไปดูดูเมืองใช่มยนะคะ
แล้วก็ไปเที่ยวกันเนี่ยก็มีอยู่ครั้งนึง
เนี่ย 2 คนเนี่ยเกือบ
แล้วกำลังจะจูบกันโอ้ปากกับปากกำลังจะมา
ใกล้กันอแม่มดเนี่ยไม่อยากจะเสียไม่อยาก
จะเอาเสียงคืนให้เค้าใช่มั้ยอยากจะเอา
เสียงเป็นของตัวเองก็เลยให้ปาลัไล 2 ตัว
ค่ะอ่าอ่านะเป็นทีมแม่มดใช่มั้ยเป็นลูก
น้องอ่านะ 2 คนกำลังจะจูบกันนะปลาไหล
มอลเล่นะ 2 ตัวก็เข้ามาแล้วก็ชนเรใช่มั้ย
ขัดขวางเอาไว้ไม่ให้ 2 คนเนี่ยจูบกัน
สำเร็จนะคะทีนี้แม่มดก็ไม่ไม่ได้กแล้วไม่
ได้กแล้วเดี๋ยว 2 คนเนี้ยได้จูบกันแน่ๆก็
เลยแปลงกายตัวตัวเองค่ะวู้แปลงกายเป็นผู้
หญิงสวยอ่าติ๊งๆง
อ่าแล้วแน่นอนใช่มั้ยมีเสียงของนางเงือก
ที่เก็บเอาไว้ใช่ก็ใช้เสียงของนางเงือกเ
ร้องเพลงเจ้าชายได้ยินโอ๊ยจำเสียงนี้ได้
นะก็คิดโอ๊ยผู้หญิงคนนี้ไงที่ช่วยเหลือ
เราเราคิดจะแต่งงานค่ะออก็เลยจะจะแต่งงาน
แต่เวลาเห็นเนี่ยแบบนี้เนาะหน้าแบบนี้แต่
เวลาดูกระจกแล้วกลายเป็นแบบนี้
ค่ะแม่หมดอื
นะ
ใช่ส่วนแียทำยังไง
คะเสียใจเนอะ
โอหวันที่ 3 เนี่ยเราจะต้องเสียเสียงไป
แน่ๆแต่เรื่องเนี้ยรู้ถึงเจ้าชาเอ่อราชา
ใช่มั้ยเอ่อเจ้าสมุทเจ้าสมุทรซึ่งเป็นพ่อ
ของเงือก
น้อยพ่อก็สงสารนะก็อยากจะช่วย
นะก็อยากจะลบล้างสิ่งที่ลูกเนี่ยสัญญาไว้
กับแม่
มดก็เลยยอมนะแลกกับ
บัลลังก์ก็คือ
นะเจ้าสมุทรตำแหน่งเจ้าสมุดรเนี่ยต้อง
ต้องเอาให้กับแม่มดใช่
นะที่เป็นปลาหมึกยักษ์เนาะเพื่อจะได้เอา
เสียงคืนให้ลูกอื
อืเมดก็โอเคมีของแลกเปลี่ยนใช่มั้ยแลกกับ
การเป็นเจ้าสมุดดูแลมหาสมุทรใหญ่ๆอุ๊ยก็
น่าสนใจนะก็เลยเอาเสียงคืนไปนะ
อื
นะพอได้คืนโหต้อง
นะก็นะราชาพระราชาเนี่ยนะที่เป็นเจ้า
สมุดรนะแต่ว่าตอนนี้ไม่ได้เป็นเจ้าสมุดร
แล้วใช่มั้ยใช่โดนสาบไปเป็นดอกไม้ทะเลนะ
อืส่วนส่วนเอ่อเงือกน้อยอยเนี่ยก็อยู่ใน
ทะเลแต่เอ่อแม่มดเนี่ยเป็นเจ้าสมุทรแล้ว
ก็เลยปอกพอมตัวเองเอแบบแปลงร่างตัวเองแบบ
ใหญ่ค่ะแล้วก็ทำคลื่นยากบืดมีพายุ
อ่าทำให้แอนกับ
อ่าใช่
นะก็แต่โชคดีนะทำให้ 2 คนได้มาเจอ
กันเจ้าชายกับเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยเนี่ยได้
มาเจอกันอีกครั้งนึงเพราะว่าเรือเนี่ยโดน
พายุใช่มั้ยนะคะแล้วก็เรือก็จมคว่ำจมอ่า
คว่ำลงไปก็เกาะเสากระโดงเรือนะเกาะเสา
กระโดงเรือแล้วก็เจอ
นะนะต่อสู้กับแม่มดใช่นะก็ก็ก็ใช้เรือ
เนี่ยค่ะสู้แล้วก็ใช้เรือเนี่ยมีเสากระดง
เลยอ่ะก็พุ่ง
ชนพุ่งชนแม่มดเลยแม่มดตายนะก็เลยทุกอย่าง
กลับมาเหมือนเดิมพ่อก็ไม่ต้องเป็นดอกไม้
ทะเลแล้วใช่พระราชาก็มีอำนาจกลับมาเป็น
พระราชาเจ้าสมุทนะมาเป็นเจ้าสมุทรดูแล
มหาสมุทรก็เลยรู้สึกว่าเออลูกรักเจ้าชาย
เนาะอือก็เลยอ่ะโอเคงั้นก็ให้ขากับลูกลูก
จะได้มีเท้ามีขามีเท้าเป็นเหมือนมนุษย์
หรือหรือว่าคนนะลูกจะได้อยู่กับคนที่ตัว
เองรักอือเหก็เลยใช้อาวุธนะต 0 นก็
เปลี่ยนรึๆๆๆเสก
ตุงโอ้โหให้นางเงือกมีขาใช่ถ้าพ่อให้ตั้ง
แต่แรกก็ไม่ต้องมีปัญหาแล้วใช่มั้ยนะแต่
พ่อเนี่ยไม่อยาก
ให้เงือกกับคนเนี่ยจะอยู่ด้วยกันได้ยังไง
อืก็พ่อก็พยายามกีดกันก่อนไงแต่รู้ว่าลูก
กับเจ้าชายเนี่ยรักกันจริงๆในที่สุดก็ขัด
ขวางไม่ได้ก็เลยให้ขากับลูกนะแล้วก็ให้ 2
คนเนี่ยให้ลูกเนี่ยไปอยู่กับเจ้าชายทั้ง 2
ก็เลยได้แต่งงานนะคะอยู่ร่วมกัน
อย่ามีความสุขแอ
โอ้โหก็เลยเป็นเจ้าหญิงเงือกน้อยเออเห็น
มยสุดท้ายแล้วเนี่ยทั้ง 2 คนก็แบบมีความ
สุขตอนจบนะใช่ค่ะนะเห็นมั้ยล่ะนิทานเนี่ย
เขาคก็จะสอนให้คนน่ะคือต้องเป็นคนดีนะอื
คนไม่ดีก็จะเจออะไรที่ไม่ดีใช่มยใช่เพราะ
ว่าแม่มดเนี่ยคิดโกงใช่มั้ยเค้ากำลังจะ
จูบกันแล้วอ่ะเค้ากำลังจะจุ๊บกันแล้ว
เนี่ยแต่ส่งปลาไหล 2 ตัวเนี่ยไปทำให้เค้า
ยุดไม่ให้จุ๊บกันนะให้เรือมันงอจุ๊บไม่
ได้
อืเห็นมั้ยแล้วเป็นที่เอ่อเราก็จะรู้ว่า
ความรักของพ่อนะอ่ะเห็นมยเจ้าสมุดอ่ะมี
ตำแหน่งนะยอมเอามงกุฎอ่ะไปแลกความปลอดภัย
ของลูกสาวรักลูกมากๆอืความรักของพ่อกับ
ลูกนะใช่ค่ะูชินะแล้วก็ยอมเสียลูกไปเป็น
คนนะเพื่อให้ลูกเนี่ยมีความสุขแต่ว่าก็
ยังได้เจอกันบ้างเนาะเพราะว่าพ่อก็สามารถ
มาเจอกับลูกได้หรือว่าลูกเนี่ยว่ายน้ำลง
ไปแบบลึกๆไม่ได้แล้วนะเพราะว่าไม่ได้มี
หางปลาแล้วอื้อหือนะลูกก็ว่ายน้ำได้แต่
ว่าน่าจะไม่ไม่ลึกมากนะก็จะไปเจอพ่อได้
นะก็สมัยก่อนเมื่อก่อนตอนเด็กๆเนาะ
นะคนเด็กๆก็จะชอบฟังไง
นิทานเอ้าแล้วยิ่งเวลาที่เราดูการ์ตูนของ
วอดินี่อ่ะเค้าก็วาดการ์ตูนสุสวยแล้วก็
น่ารักไงเวลาเราดูก็แบบ
อื้อหืออยากเป็นเจ้า
หญิงดูไปด้วยแล้วก็ฝันไป
ด้วยถ้าฉันเป็นเจ้าหญิงครูชิมีหางเป็นปลา
นะได้ว่ายน้ำไม่ต้องมีแทงค์ออกซิเจนนะ
คุณูชิก็จะไหยน้ำไปนะแล้วก็ไม่ต้องเสีย
ค่าเครื่องบินเนาะนะไม่ต้องที่ TG
แอร์ไลนนะไม่ต้องเอ่อบางกอกแอร์เวไม่ต้อง
ไม่ต้องเสียเงินค่ะว่ายน้ำไปเองค่ะครูชิ
ก็เลยมีมีหางปลาค่ะครูชิก็อยากจะเป็นหนัง
เงือกครูชิก็ไปเอาครูชิมีกางเกงใช่
มยครูชิก็ที่นี่เลยค่ะใส่มีขามีขา 1 ขา 2
อยู่ที่นี่
เอาเอาอีกข้างนึงเนี่ยมาพันมามัด
เอวมัดจนเป็นแบบอยู่ที่อกแบบนี้อ่า little
mermaid แล้วไปไหนก็กระโดดไป
ค่ะกระดึ๊บ
ค่ะไม่ใช่หนอนใช่
มั้ยกระดึ๊บ
เนี่ยคุณพ่อคุณพ่อ
คุณพ่อ
นี่ครูชิใช่มยครูชิคุณพ่อเนี่ย
ลูกไม่สบายหรือ
เปล่าตัวร้อนหรือเปล่ากี่้าเซลเซียสไม่
สบายพ่อคิดว่าไม่สบายเข้าใจมยกางเกงอ่ะ
เนี่ยกางเกงอ่ะกางเกงก็ต้องใส่ที่นี่ 1
ขาที่นี่ 1 ขาอ๋อไม่เห็นค่ะขยบเออ
อันเนี้ยถูกแต่ใส่แบบเนี้ยผิดค่ะ 2 ขา
กางเกงที่นี่ 1 แล้วมี 1 ขา 2 ขาแบบนี้
อันนี้ผิดค่ะ
อแต่เป็นเมอเมดไงเมอเมดต้องต้องขาเนี่ย
ต้องติดกันค่ะพ่อไม่รู้ไงพ่อบอกไอคิวไม่
ดีหรอไอคิวเนี่ยใส่กางเกงต้องแบบนี้ไม่
ใช่แบบนี้ครูชิบอกเป็นเงือกน้อยค่ะ
พ่อแล้วแล้วพ่อถามมว่าจะไปว่ายน้ำที่
ไหนพ่อเป็นเงือกน้อยแล้วครูชิเนี่ยผมสั้น
ค่ะครูชิก็ต้องไปเอาผ้าเช็ดตัวค่ะแล้วครู
ชิก็มาทำเป็นผมยาวครูปุ๊กอืตอนนั้นอายุ
เท่าไหร่อ่ะคะ 4 ขวบ
ค่ะ Little เมอร์เมดผมยาว
ค่ะเห็นมยมีจินตนาการ
นะเป็นเงือกน้อยค่ะคุณพ่อโอเข้าใจแล้วครู
ชินะเข้าใจตอนนี้ทำไมมีเงือกน้อยขายเป็น
ชุดเพราะว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยเด็กๆเนาะก็อ่าน
หนังสือนิทานแบบนี้แหละนะแล้วก็ดูเป็นแบบ
ตอนนี้เนี่ยเป็นการ์ตูนใช่มยนะภาพก็สวย
เด็กๆก็จะชอบนะชอบฟังชอบแล้วก็เคทำชุดออก
มาเนสำหรับขายเด็กๆก็สวยค่ะทุกคนก็เปิดหา
อยากได้ชุดสีเขียวสีฟ้าสีชมพูโอ้โหทีนี้
นางเงือกเต็มไปหมดเลย
ค่ะแต่ใส่ไปงานปาร์ตี้โรงเรียน
นะแล้วก็ไปเล่นตึมๆตึม
เฮ้อคิดถึงเด็กๆนะนะตอนเนี้ยคิดถึงไม่ได้
แล้วอ่ะทำไมอ่ะหมดอ้าหมดเวลาแล้วหรอคะใช่
ค่ะไม่มีเวลาแล้วออ้าอย่าเลยจะไปใส่ชุด
นางเงือกไปว่ายน้ำใช่มั้ย
อืเก็บไว้เก็บ
ไว้ไม่บอกไม่บครูชิเนี่ยสั่งซื้อมาแล้ว
ค่ะชุดนางเงือกค่ะเดี๋ยวูชิเเนี่ยจะไป
ไหวยน้ำ
ค่ะมีสระน้ำใช่มั้ยอพาร์ทเมนต์มีสระน้ำ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ไหว้คิดว่าจะมีคนเห็นแล้วบอกว่าอายุเท่า
ไหร่
อืเค้าไม่รู้หรอกตอนนี้เนี่ยไฮไลท์ไฮไลท์
เอ้อค่ะูปุ๊กวันนี้เราต้องลานักเรียนไป
ก่อนค่ะเวลาหมดอมดเวลาอ่าแล้วก็คราวหน้า
เนี่ยครูปุ๊กครูชิก็จะหานิทานสนุกๆมาเล่า
ให้นักเรียนฟังเป็นภาษาไทยนะคะ
อวันนี้นักเรียนรู้จักเงือกน้อยเจ้าสมุด
แม่มดเจ้าชายเจ้าหญิงอืเยอะแยะอืก็ไว้พบ
กันในคลิปต่อไปนะคะมีคอมเมนต์อะไรก็เขียน
มาได้ค่ะชอบเจ้าหญิงคน
เออนักเรียนอยากเป็นเจ้าหญิงคนไหนเขียนมา
บอกครูปุ๊กกับครูชิด้วยค่ะนะวันนี้ชอบ
เหมือนครูชิหรือเปล่าอ่าเราก็ลาทุกคนไป
ก่อนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊